how long does it take to become a Navy
SEAL you got to go through boot camp
which is just typical Navy boot camp
that's 2 months long it's in Chicago
when I went through there was a a
mandatory Preparatory School where for
two more months you stay in Chicago and
you train with like literally
professional athletes and coaches and
Olympic athletes who have been brought
in by the Navy to build up your strength
build up your confidence because your
next phase is actual like Navy SEAL boot
camp in Coronado California it's like
the most stunningly beautiful place ever
in this like iconic place there's like
the most treacherous military training
like ever taking place and it's very
public you can like watch it they want
it to be borderline impossible to do so
that if you are able to complete the
training you've demonstrated that you
can kind of push beyond what most people
would consider an impossible limit it's
called basic underwater demolition SL
seal school or buds for short and to get
through that you're virtually guaranteed
to become a seal like the attrition rate
Falls to near zero at that point